les chéris c'est vrai qu'à la main à
deux jours de la grande finale de koh
lanta aujourd'hui la finale et remise en
cause alors gilles vous avez encore des
infos oui les sur les dessous du pacte
donc scellé entre les quatre finalistes
javier rascal clémence et jérémy qui ont
donc décidé de se partager la somme de
cent mille euros 25 x 4 25 minutes
chacun d'eux d'hier voilà je vais vous
raconter comment donc ravir et pascal
sont amis depuis avant la compétition
commencera ils se connaissent donc ce
qu'elles se connaissent ils ont aidé
reconnaît pascale wilhelmy sirigu n'a
que la précédente édition il oui c'est
vrai ils ont décidé d'aller au bout
ensemble ils se sont dits qu'associé
clémence était particulièrement
intelligent parce que clémence avait
déjà fait un pacte financier voulait le
faire quand elle avait gagné 2010 effet
sur comme elle est très douée qu'elle
irait loin mais voilà en revanche j'ai
eu plusieurs candidates et candidats
jérémy a été associé au dernier moment
jérémy texto il a suivi le mouvement
au début il ne voulait pas mes textos il
vous envoyer un texto est longue il a
dit ne voulait pas alors ça sème la
zizanie
oui parce que pascal souvenez-vous j'ai
la preuve avait publié une photo sur un
steinway
il y à quelques temps et cette photo
c'était comme par hasard voilà comme et
c'est avant qu'ils restent tous les cas
traités avant et c'était celle des
quatre finalistes c'était avant qu'on
sache que ce serait des quatre fils ont
les mêmes et on recommence
après des centaines de messages positifs
me demandant d'ignorer les ignorants
voilages et la décision de continuer
donc ça prouve que la triche est
explicite
comme par hasard on les retrouve tous
les quatre c'est fou comment est ce que
c'est vraiment de la blanche c'est vrai
des mineurs est d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens anciens et nouveaux sont venus vers
moi aujourd'hui après les révélations et
m'ont dit c'est pas possible c'est
honteux parce qu'au fil de la
compétition ils ont éliminé les gens qui
ne voulaient pas entrer dans la marine
les pauses et les anciens des anciens
les gens me disent ils voient sont en
train de tuer l'esprit colombes
c'est pour cela que beaucoup ne veulent
pas venir à la finale alors on en soit
réduite on aura la grosse info du jour
dans un instant pour savoir qui a arrêté
les messieurs à vous s'était arrêté
l'émission pardon juste d'un mot qu'est
ce qu'il ya de choquant ça saigne
stratège oui la première émission de
télé réalité les gens première
éventuellement être à 3 et avoir plus de
chances de gagner 100 milliards à jack
avoir une chance sur 10 lui pour
témoigner et benoît maraîcher stratège
pour partager le tout les jeux de télé
répond surtout à ses skis se magne sais
pas c'est pas une première parce que si
comme je lé fais on regarde un peu les
archives et la presse et vous se rend
compte que dans les précédentes éditions
pas sur le moment pas sur la saison même
mais une fois que la saison est passé
ils finissent tous par cracher le
morceau et en 2008 dans le parisien
christelle la gagnante de la saison
élite reconnaît avoir partagé les cent
mille euros de ses gains elle l'a fait
avec bertrand et frédéric qui était avec
avec elle sur les poteaux en 2012 c'est
combat qui nous qui raconte elle aussi
la même chose en disant il ya eu un
impact financier
sauf que finalement ce pas donc c'est
déjà la saison
alors oui mais même dans la traque
rappelez-vous michel il a partagé avec
je sais plus qui l'affirmé il avait volé
l'orangé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque ces terminaux bon c'est vrai
alors oui oui